Adrien sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale cela pourrait bientôt devenir
une image d'archives accusé de violences
conjugales contre son épouse alors que
la France insoumise préparait son retour
au Palais Bourbon le député du Nord ne
participera plus aux activités
politiques de son groupe jusqu'à nouvel
ordre certaines femmes vivent parfois
l'enfer derrière les volets clos des
maisons et soyez incertains ça touche
tous les milieux je ne sais pas si
Monsieur katnas appartient à ces traces
d'hommes qui construisent une image
publique si différente de ce qu'ils sont
dans l'intimité je sais une chose un
homme ça s'empêche comme disait Albert
Camus
on devrait peut-être se trouver un petit
ami taliban
un taliban stylé
il est tu rigoles leur style est facile
à imiter tu ne prends pas de douche
pendant une semaine
tu mets juste de l'huile dans tes
cheveux tu mets les mêmes vêtements pas
besoin de les laver et quand tu manges
tu fais tout dégoulinets dans ta barbe
de la même manière qu'un homme qui
harcèle ou qui ennuie ou qui se conduit
mal avec une femme il ne le fait jamais
une fois
je vous le dis très respectueusement
amicalement on s'en moque de ce que vous
croyez ou penser ah non j'avais déjà
parce que c'est pas le sujet je suis pas
d'accord
soyez pas d'accord mais c'est pas le
sujet et tu t'adore
là c'est compliqué je peux pas me voir
toute la journée
et tu te fais des bisous dans le
téléphone quand tu te film
et se met en fond d'écran
[Musique]
c'est pour éviter qu'il ne crache sur
les curieux
on lui a mis un masque comme ça pour
éviter que les gens aient peur de lui
mais il ne crache jamais sur les
inconnus
Théo vous nous expliquez votre look
c'était la mode Haute-Savoie ça
le style style je me suis dit bon le
thème c'est fromage on va mettre le
jaune et puis bon vu que ce t-shirt du
coup il y avait le mono-souris je me
suis dit on va s'accorder et puis du
coup on va faire voilà le mono-sourcide
CET alpaga c'est une star il s'appelle
million comme son nombre de fans sur la
version chinoise de Tik Tok une vidéo
par semaine beaucoup de mise en scène et
beaucoup d'accessoires
parce qu'on n'y est pas
encore ah oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
mignon un serre-tête très mignon en
forme de carotte c'est adorable comme si
la carotte avait poussé dans son oreille
ah mais là je sors un carton rouge
interplanétaire et vous pouvez nous le
montrer votre chien moi ça
m'intéresserait de le voir votre gros
chien ah on va le voir votre gros chien
là
on voit pas il est où le chien il est
alors ça c'est
pas du tout c'est vous qu'on voit donc
là c'est vous que je vois donc il est où
le chien il est où ah là là il va
falloir se mettre comme ça là une
proposition de loi du député LFI aymeric
Caron qui dénonce la maltraitance
animale et qui souhaite donc l'abolir ça
acteurait quelque chose de très fort
pour nous dans notre rapport à l'animal
oh comment il s'appelle
appelle Luis Mariano Louise ça tombe
bien tout à l'heure on a une chanson de
Luis Mariano bah oui vous voyez parler
il était malheureux bonjour bonjour Luis
Mariano
il est pas très gentil bah ouais c'est
le problème des animaux
bon c'est pas une tradition française
au départ historique et ça devient
personne le couscous ne tue personne
aimerait Caron 24 novembre 2020 c'est
Solveig qui est là Solveig qui est qui
nous donnera son avis dans un instant
alors Cathy est-ce qu'on peut vous
décaler qu'un Solveig va s'asseoir
[Rires]
une boucherie fondée en 1926 où vous
pouvez déguster ces petites croquettes
cromesquis de bœuf de Kobé qui coûte à
peine 2 euros mais il y a une liste
d'attente combien de temps d'attente 10
ans 32 ans 32 ans
comme ça on peut discuter
[Musique]
c'est la rechute oui 32 il faut
descendre dans les arènes il faut
descendre dans les libérer les martyres
c'est pas possible et c'est parler les
autres
c'est la caca c'est la cata
la catastrophe merci de suivre mesdames
à qui tu parles à qui tu
[Applaudissements]
au début mais voilà on aimerait bien un
petit peu de calme je trouve que c'est
c'est plus respectueux envers nous tous
quoi